hey guys what's up I'm Alana what
Charlotte and welcome to part 2 of my
math unboxing slash nerd whole video
where things are getting pretty
expensive what's next I think we're
gonna go with scarlet which yeah she is
a limited edition 451 out of 850 statue
by Bowen designs 14 inches tall and I
just think it's awesome so this statue
of the box here says 230 dollars but I
bought her for much much less I got her
at the same convention that I bought
groot at from the exact same store so I
kind of got a deal for the two of them
so while it says 230 dollars
I actually got half the 70 and here she
is I think she's beautiful
I bought her I think it was like a month
or two ago I absolutely love the classic
scarlet witch design and you know how
some women feel about one woman as being
like their icon I would much prefer to
be Scarlet Witch then Wonder Woman
colors are lovely and I like opposed her
expression is kind of bland but it's
still very cool obviously much bigger
than the others and she's much more
solid material where all the other
things that I showed you what kind of
bendy she is probably made of something
extremely breakable but I I really
really like her pose I really like the
colors again I love this shine that
looks extremely cool my criticism here
is that her hair is very matte sculpting
has definitely gone into this but it's
all really one color
there's no highlight or anything like
that of course being a statue she is not
going to stand up by myself sometimes as
they do but very often they do come with
these pins for their bases when things
are collector's items so you can have
the number on the base so the base is a
nice little Avengers logo that we just
slide her into voila I usually wouldn't
keep the box for anything that isn't a
collector's item so obviously for
Scarlet Witch I will be keeping the box
and the form that came with it
next up and another New York City retail
purchase
dr. Manhattan very fittingly I bought
him in Manhattan I got him at Midtown
comics in Manhattan I don't remember how
much they paid but I think it was a
hundred and thirty says here 149 95 so
probably that much he's a cold cast also
on Statue just part of the DC Comics
collection
90 is 10.5 inches high very very cool
color nice but there is tons of
beautiful muscle detail but no shading
at all which I kind of would expect
being that he's transparent obvious
flaws his actual arms have obviously
been joined on at a later date to the
rest of his body so you can very clearly
see lines where they've been connected
which is kind of a shame see there you
can see pretty much exactly where that's
been joined up and it's the same for
this one as well which is a shame
another big old statue he also comes
with a very cool face that says dr.
Manhattan so be slutting him in there
and he faces forward despite the
transparency being very cool and making
him one of the most unique statues that
I have I am really disappointed with
those joints but the detail and the
muscles are impressive but okay what's
next
Jesus I'm making so much mess right now
that's just stuff everywhere on the
floor but let's pretend that's not
because you guys can't see it t brick
next to this giant box also doubles as a
very effective headrest it's Batman and
Robin this is DC all-stars / DC direct
and it measures approximately 9.5 inches
height 11.25 inches wide and 9.5 inches
depth and it's based on that awesome
image so I just really liked always it
really stood out to me I did ponder
whether or not to buy it for a while but
I actually got it on free coin all day
where the store that I went to free
comic book day which was last week ish
was having a 25 percent off sale on
everything including statues so I went
for it again as soon as I saw it I made
sure to check online for how much it
might be worth but when I searched for
him online I could even find him could
be because he's I think 975 of one
thousand three
hundred but it could also be that Batman
and Robin is such a broad search that a
million other things came sir we have
the cool base here with a like fake
Gotham City skyline for our heroes to
stand on yeah
look Batman I love the pose I want the
way to Kate blocks his face is fairly
blank again another statue with not much
detail there isn't any shading there are
no stents and he's there but aside from
that few minor painting areas not
incredible quality but I actually didn't
get this one for the quality I just
loved the pose and Robin again some kind
of obvious mistakes on the all where
it's not perfectly straight very plain
expression not totally awesome quality
but nonetheless all together extremely
freakin cool I love the way that this
looks I love the companionship I love
the idea of having Gotham City in the
background and I like the size of it as
well it's a big one that's what she said
so I remember how much Batman and Robin
were but I think they were 150 I think
I'm unfortunately not actually sure so
it was the most expensive book punch but
I actually have one last thing to unbox
that I've kept to last because it's a
sword and it happens to be a Master
Sword
it's heavy so we'd already have a
monster sword back home but this one is
much nice quality and I believe that it
would have been around the same price as
the first one that I got I also bought
this one at a convention the same
convention that I bought Scarlet Witch
and Guardians the galaxy groot at where
I was cosplaying as sub-zero thanks to
my friend Eckrich who left sign prints
in here now that's so it's actually
telling me that it's $65 oh my god it's
so much heavier than I thought it would
be and it's gonna get mess everywhere
Master Sword that's the price tag that's
on there right now
and there are lots of bits of fun
because it's a [ __ ] box so I love
that it has the engraving there if you
can see it you can slightly see it I
think but I also just really like the
detail in the actual handle
but perfectly made there's somewhere on
that the yellow is actually fading to
silver and you can see the lines on the
pommel from where it's been connected
but it's a nice metallic you paint and
really I was buying it for the actual
blade more than anything which I think
looks gorgeous it's extremely thick so
don't actually sharp but heavy enough
food you don't like beat the crap out of
someone if that's what you're into maybe
break some pots so because I can get it
for you guys to see master so this one
also comes with some screws and a board
to hang it up which I'm not actually
going to show you because I really don't
want to lose any of the parts of it so
worried about that so that is the end of
this ridiculous unboxing so now I have a
giant pile of boxes that I need to clean
up so just to reiterate for kind of care
if you're planning on traveling for
anything that comes with foam it comes
with foam for a reason so all the things
that came in fine boxes I will keep the
foam and the boxes and when I travel I
will take the phone back up and I will
take the boxes up and the rest of course
it's best if you keep it in the box but
if you can't they will be totally fine
if you just wrap them in clothing they
aren't collector's items so you're not
going to benefit hugely by keeping the
box
I understand some people like to do that
I personally do I think that's it took a
very long time but I hope you guys
enjoyed it I love this stuff so much
I'm Ilona thank you guys so much for
watching and I will see you next time